[Musique]
me
et
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat les missions qui
vous fait vivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée vous allez suivre ce matin une
audition de la commission d' enquête du
sénat sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
les sénateurs ont auditionné les
différents services d'urgence mobilisées
pendant cette épidémie et parmi eux les
sapeurs-pompiers qui dénonce la gestion
de crise opérée par les agences
régionales de santé
je vous laisse écouter cette audition
j'ai souhaité mes chers collègues
cette parenthèse dans nos éditions dans
la crise de position dans la série des
auditions pardon que nous menons
actuellement sur la gestion de la crise
dans différents territoires à la suite
de la diffusion dans la presse
au cours du week-end des 4 et 5 juillet
de citation d'un document de retour
d'expérience sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire émanant de la fédération
nationale des sapeurs-pompiers de france
ce document dont nous avons eu
communication de la synthèse sous une
forme provisoire et dont nous vous
demandons la version définitive dresse
un constat très sévère
considérant je cite que je cite les
événements ont été administrés plus que
gérée par la santé conduisant à
privilégier le contrôle sur la prise
d'initiative et de responsabilité des
acteurs de terrain
je ferme la parenthèse il évoque une
j'ouvre la parenthèse crise de
leadership et de communication le ferme
la parenthèse tout en soulignant plus
loin que on ouvre à nouveau la
parenthèse la coopération entre les
sapeurs-pompiers les acteurs de santé
s'est organisée globalement de mahdia
satisfaisantes au niveau local il
considère enfin que trop souvent la
doctrine a semblé devoir s'adapter aux
moyens 7,1 thèse comporte également
trois affirmations à mes yeux grave
première observation
il aurait eu des pressions il y aurait
eu des pressions sur les territoires en
tension pour abaisser le niveau de
protection de leurs agents deuxième
point des requérants non qu'on vide en
situation d'urgence vitale n'ont jamais
eu de réponses du 15 à leur appel et
sont morts dans l'indifférence générale
troisième point les évacuations par tgv
serait de pure opération de
communication sur ces trois affirmations
nous attendons des données précises et
des explications nous avons également
donc demandé au docteur delebecque de
nous faire part de son expérience pour
ce personnel de cette crise et au
docteur prud'hommes de nous exposer les
remontées des médecins urgentistes au
regard de la synthèse faite par les
sapeurs pompiers
mais pas uniquement ce qui est à dire
premièrement c'est que le document qui a
été exploité par la presse et un
document de travail donc il ya certaines
terme et certaines affirmations qui
étaient à l'intérieur qu'ils sont
erronés que nous avons souhaité corriger
c'est un groupe de travail qui se
voulait faire des remontées terrain et
donc il n'avait pas vocation à être
distribués nous plaidons non coupable
sur ce cette diffusion est par contre
responsable c'est clair je remarquerai
je ferai remarquer la commission
denquête que bon nombre d'éléments du
ministère de l'intérieur durant la crise
sont parues dans la presse notamment
dans le canard enchaîné d'autres et
d'autres éléments et cela est assez
perturbant d'avoir eu ce document de
travail et savoir à qui cela pouvait
bien nuire et notamment probablement au
dgs cgc au ministre de l'intérieur et à
la fédération nationale certainement et
nous trouvons cela très regrettable vous
dire aussi monsieur le président et
messieurs les membres de la commission
denquête que lorsque les
sapeurs-pompiers font remonter leurs
éléments et du fonds de manière eia here
are chic et c'est ce qui a été fait
aussi pour cette synthèse qui est
dorénavant finale et que vous avez eu ou
que vous allez avoir la hiérarchie pour
nous c'est le directeur général situe à
des civils le luxe de l'intérieur il ne
l'avait pas vocation à blessés ayant
tous les cas c'était sûr
tout à partager ce que nous avions
ressenti perçu et ce que nous voulons
mettre en exergue
et lorsque l'on fait un retour
d'expérience comme on a l'habitude de le
faire sur le terrain sur chacune de nos
opérations au quotidien les gens ne sont
pas en cause sont les systèmes où les
modes opératoires qu'il faut regarder
il y a des gens formidables il ya des
acteurs de sécurité de santé de sécurité
et de protection civile sont des gens
formidables et qui ont le vrai durant la
crise en mettant toutes leurs énergies
en mettant le mouchoir sur beaucoup
d'éléments notamment le temps familial
le temps professionnel pour faire en
sorte qu'il soit engagé dans cette crise
et dans la région la résolution des
problématiques par contre effectivement
nous avons pointé un certain nombre
d'éléments roland factuel parfois et
dureau ce domaine du ressenti aussi sur
le fait que cette crise n'avait pas
respecté les canaux les canaux habituels
de la gestion de crise et typiquement on
a le plan pandémique népal de 2011 qui
évoqué un certain nombre de principes
qui sont dans la synthèse et qui n'ont
pas été respectées en cela typiquement
une crise sanitaire
c'est une crise de protection civile
c'est une crise qui implique plusieurs
ministères qui multisectorielle et le
fait d'avoir confié au ministère la
santé qui est un choix délibérément le
fait d'avoir confié à la santé le
pilotage notamment dans les premiers
temps de cette crise peut appeler
questionnement et la raison et c'est la
raison pour laquelle une foule bon et
demandons pourquoi effectivement le plan
2011 n'a pas été purement et simplement
respecter pour confier également la
gestion et tous les outils du ministère
de l'intérieur de cette crise au
bénéfice et au profit du premier
ministre
en mettant finalement autour de la table
l'ensemble des secteurs impactés
notamment des ministères nous pensons
que cette crise aurait dû respecter
trois principes de la gestion de crise
habituellement qui font la gestion de
crise dans notre pays
le premier élément c'est le commandement
unique et on a relevé plusieurs
directeurs plusieurs décideurs de crise
au cours des évènements avec plusieurs
ministères parfait
a ayant des cellules de crise donc cela
appelé à interpeller en termes de
doctrine de conduite des opérations
il y a eu pour nous un élément
perturbant parce qu quotidienne et
depuis que je parle
vous avez des directeurs des opérations
de secours que sont nos mères que son au
préfet que son au préfet de zone qui eux
n'ont pas eu la main sur la gestion de
crise et qui pour autant ce sont les
interlocuteurs privilégiés des
différents acteurs des résolution de
problématiques au quotidien nos élus
locaux nos forces de police la santé
l'ensemble des acteurs et des
associations agrées de sécurité civile
l'ensemble de la médecine et le l'offre
de soins des territoires les maires et
les préfets ont l'habitude de les avoir
effectivement un interlocuteur
privilégié et enfin ceux tous ces
acteurs que je cite constituer la
résilience du territoire que ce soit une
pandémie
la chaîne que l'on avait connu que ce
soit d inonder des inondations de cet
espace naturel ou tout autre sinistre
typiquement comme lubrizol
ce sont les mêmes acteurs d'une cité qui
répondent à chaque fois à l'unisson sous
un seul commandement sous une seule
direction des opérations de secours
vous disiez monsieur le président qu on
a eu l'impression effectivement que la
crise avait été administré plutôt que
gérer conduisant à privilégier
effectivement des initiatives locales
je voulais revenir sur ceux sur cette
thématique parce que on ne peut pas de
notre point de vue gérer une crise comme
on a l'habitude d'administrer un
établissement public comme on a
l'habitude administré une administration
tout simplement parce que la gestion de
crise exige d'avoir des fondamentaux et
de prendre des décisions dans l'urgence
ce que font les militaires ce que
s'affairent les gendarmes les policiers
ce qu'elles savent faire les sapeurs
pompiers des collègues urgentistes aussi
avec nous qui sont sur le terrain
mais pour autant celles et ceux qui sont
en illustration centrale ou par ailleurs
c'est beaucoup pas c'est pas parfois
beaucoup plus difficile pour eux parce
que leurs paradigmes habituels ne sont
pas ceux de la gestion de crise et
notamment pour reprendre un terme qui a
été exploité par le président la
république notamment une crise qui s'est
révélé être une guerre contre le coc
vite 19 donc en temps de guerre
effectivement
les paradigmes sont totalement
différentes du temps habituel ce
ressenti que nous avons qui est traduit
dans la synthèse finale
je souhaite le dire elle affirmé il est
partagé par bon nombre d'acteurs de
terrain que ce soit de la médecine de
ville
des infirmiers libéraux l'hériter rynair
d'autres acteurs de la sécurité
finalement ce sont plutôt les
territoires qui ont eu ce sentiment là
parfois avec des élus locaux aussi c'est
cela était très hétérogène
les difficultés ont été vécue très
différemment selon aussi la capacité ou
la personnalité des différents acteurs
des différentes décideurs pour ce qui
est de la sollicitation des
sapeurs-pompiers nous avons une
participation qui n'étaient pas à la
hauteur de ce que nous faisons au
quotidien
il faut savoir que les sapeurs pompiers
sont de notre point de vue et cela peut
paraître corporatiste mais l'idée c'est
pas de faire du corporatisme c'est
surtout de mettre en exergue ce qui se
passe au quotidien
les sapeurs-pompiers sont les acteurs de
la santé du territoire avec d'autres
acteurs très certainement mais ce sont
celles et ceux qui avec 7000 caserne
avec des 150000 personnels qu'ils soient
militaires à paris et marseille qu'ils
soient professionnels qu'ils soient
volontaires surtout puisque 80% des
sapeurs pompiers sont volontaires
ils sont la réponse de la santé des
territoires avec leurs ambulances
puisqu'aujourd'hui les soldats du feu
sont devenus des soldats de la santé et
il effectue que de 4 16 millions
d'interventions au bénéfice de la santé
au bénéfice du secours d'urgence aux
personnes dans tous nos territoires et
dessinateur auquel je m'adresse savent
très bien ce à quoi ça correspond au
quotidien pour autant il y a eu un
sentiment une perception que c'était
tout sauf les pompiers et heureusement
heureusement que l'ensemble des
relations qui font que au quotidien les
urgentistes les hôpitaux les sapeurs
pompiers travaillent ensemble ce mot
d'ordre qui était plutôt lancé
visiblement au niveau national ou que
nous avons perçu n'a pas été entendu
pas été exécuté c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a eu effectivement une
réactivité et vous me disiez monsieur le
président des actions complémentaires
qui ont permis de réagir avec
pragmatisme et proximité ces actions
complémentaires
ça a été l'action des sapeurs pompiers
aux bénéfices au profit de nos
concitoyens plus de cent mille
interventions effectuées la plupart des
des transport héliporté près de 50%
d'entre eux ont été effectuées par les
hélicoptères de la sécurité civile et
nous citons les sapeurs-pompiers mais
c'est tout le modèle de sécurité civile
qui a réagi et tout cela en lien avec
les collègues des hôpitaux
cela a été le renforcement des centres
d'appels cela était le renforcement des
tris à l'arrivée aux hôpitaux avec les
passages qu'ovide ou les passages non
qu'ovide cela était également les phases
de tests qui ont été faits durant dans
les ehpad dans les collèges dans toutes
les entités dans lesquelles il a fallu
ensuite relancer l'activité économique
de notre pays
donc les sapeurs pompiers ont pu
lorsqu'il était sollicité par les ars ou
de propre initiative lorsque des élus
locaux ou les préfets les ont mis
finalement au devant faire en sorte que
la résilience et l'accompagnement du
coup lead ou la lutte contre le coc vite
puisse se faire avec leur aide
les sapeurs pompiers ne réclame pas plus
que cela en termes de connaissance ils
le disent seulement que comme il est
effectué 84 % de leurs chants
missionnaires sur les secours d'urgence
aux personnes
pourquoi en temps de guerre ne pas les
avoir sollicité plus que cela et les
avoir finalement mis de côté à un moment
donné alors que la force des sapeurs
pompiers
c'est l'engagement citoyen ce sont les
sapeurs pompiers volontaires
il y avait de la disponibilité il y
avait des gens avec des compétences du
secours d'urgence au quotidien il y a
des médecins il y à des infirmiers il y
a des gens capables de faire énormément
de choses et tout cela n'a pas était
naturellement sollicité par moments de
manière très hétérogène la gestion
locale cette crise elle doit sa réussite
à 4
quatre facteurs le premier élément c'est
ce lien que je disais et que j'évoquais
entre les maires et les sapeurs pompiers
ce lien inaltérable entre les
territoires et les sapeurs-pompiers qui
sont les territoires au quotidien c'est
également cette agilité les sénateurs
que vous êtes connaissent bien
l'organisation de la sécurité civile ce
sont des 10 des établissements publics
qui ont montré leur robustesse qui ont
montré leur agilité leur capacité de
réponse opérationnelle
donc on peut dire que la
départementalisation est une vraie
réussite au bout de vingt ans tout cela
animé et dirigé par la direction
générale de la sécurité civile
le troisième point c'est ce que j'ai
évoqués c'est ce modèle hybride entre
pompiers professionnels pompiers
volontaires et vous savez au sénat qu'il
est intéressant et important de rappeler
l'utilité du volontariat la défense et
nous y reviendrons certainement en
conclusion le quatrième point
c'est ce lien inaltérable que personne
ne pourra attaquer que personne ne
pourra remettre en question même si
d'aucuns veulent parler de guerre rouge
blanc il n'y a pas de guerre rouge blanc
est en tous les cas les rouges ne
souhaite pas la guerre avec les blancs
pour une seule et unique raison c'est
que nous travaillons régulièrement sur
le terrain ensemble
en revanche oui il y à des systèmes a
revisité il y a des paradigmes des
années de la fin des années 80 qui ont
permis notre résistance notre résilience
notre réponse aux secours d'urgence aux
personnes pendant dix à vingt ans mais
aujourd'hui notre société a évolué et
nous devons faire évoluer nos systèmes
de réponse en matière de médecine
d'urgence en matière de traitement des
appels en matière de secours d'urgence
tout simplement ce que je voulais
évoquer aussi c'est cette nécessité de
refonte en profondeur du système de
santé qui est fondée sur une
territorialité particulière et avec
nécessaire attribution clair au
ministère de l'intérieur de la gestion
de crise il y a aussi une nouvelle
ambition à posséder pour la protection
civile nous on appelle cela la sécurité
civile
mais tous les pays européens appellent
cela la protection civile
premièrement
système de santé vous avez évoqué les
tgv ce que nous avons vu ce que nous
savons c'est que vous alliez des
colonnes de renfort de sapeurs pompiers
qui étaient prêtes constitué avec des
ambulances des médecins larmes au pied
tel que vous allez le voir tout au long
de l'été lorsque les camions descendront
dans le sud de la france où renforceront
pour les feux des espaces naturels ces
colonnes étaient prêtes
les personnels ont été renvoyés chez eux
quelques temps après nous avons entendu
parler des tgv avec de belles opérations
de communication ses tgv ont été
construits bâti l'idée est intéressante
notamment lorsque les attentes à 2015
ont frappé notre pays pour évacuer des
victimes d'attentats sur d'autres
centres hospitaliers pour les recevoir
et des techniques et mais pour autant
pourquoi ne pas avoir utilisé les
ressources qui était en place qui
étaient mobilisés c'est la question que
nous posons
pourquoi ne pas avoir mobilisé plus que
cela les cliniques privées par ailleurs
c'est toutes ces questions que nous nous
posons sur le terrain il n'y a pas de
remise en cause particulière du schéma
en revanche on se pose des questions
et quand on voit énormément de
communication autour d'un seul vecteur
ça amène encore plus de questionnements
ensuite nous avons évoqué tout le
travail que nous avons fait dans les
ehpad
oui nous avons alerté nous avons été
alertés
parce que nous avons perçu vu dans les
ehpad ou tout début veut dire que cela
nous laisse et hagard par moments oui on
a fait remonter les situations et c'est
la raison pour laquelle aussi la plupart
des indices se sont mis à accompagner
les phases de test dans les ehpad pour
permettre justement aux soignants aux
accompagnants aux patients d'être pris
en compte dans ces établissements pour
nos anciens
vous avez évoqué aussi j'ai évoqué le
sujet de la refondation du traitement de
l'alerté
aujourd'hui et durant la crise on dit
qu'il faut appeler le 15 tout le temps
c'est un principe je veux vous dire que
si vous aviez dit s'il avait été dit
il faut appeler le 18 août ans pendant
la crise le 18 aurait été saturé de la
même manière que le 15
nous ne disons pas que le 18 ou tout
autre numéro sur aurait été meilleur en
termes de réponse que le centre 15
en revanche ce que nous évoquons est ce
que nous réclamons c'est un travail
interservices au quotidien avec des
plateformes départemental de réception
des appels d'urgence pour permettre de
traiter de l'accident cardiaque dans des
temps qui permette de sauver la plupart
nos concitoyens alors qu'aujourd'hui
nous mettons la grippe
le conseil médical l'accident cardiaque
l'accident de la route dans les mêmes
tuyaux
nous souhaitons qu'il y ait un numéro
d'appel d'urgence unique comme dans la
plupart des pays européens le 112 avec
des centres départementaux d'appel
d'urgence et permettre la construction
d'un service d'accès aux soins avec un
numéro dédié qui est déjà testé dans
trois régions
le 116 117 faire de burj d'un côté et
d'une non urgents et du conseil médical
de l'autre oui nous le souhaitons et
pour cela nous devons avoir des centres
départementaux d'appel d'urgence dans
lequel l'ensemble des services de
réponse à l'urgence doivent travailler
ensemble
j'utiliserai une métaphore d'un
président de conseil départemental qui
utilisent effectivement le syndrome de
la machine à café
lorsque les gens travaillent ensemble au
quotidien ils sont que meilleur lorsque
finalement ils ont une crise à gérer
et enfin pour terminer nous demandons
une vraie ambition de sécurité civile de
protection civile
alors pour cela il y a deux hypothèses
première hypothèse soit au long conforte
le livre blanc de 2008 et les
orientations qui était enviée sur la dgs
cgc et la refondation qui est la sienne
depuis 2011
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin que
cela la dgs cgc le budget de la sécurité
civile est un budget qui est le moindre
dans la partie du ministère de
l'intérieur au niveau de l'état la
sécurité civile ces 5 milliards d'euros
la plupart de ce budget là ce sont les
10 qui le confère et aujourd'hui nous
avons un sujet de renouvellement des
machines notamment des hélicoptères de
sécurité civile nous avons un sujet des
avions bombardiers d'eau
des investissements sont en cours et
sont réalisés nous avons le sujet de
l'accompagnement des territoires dans
les investissements lourds il faut
répondre à cet enjeu de pandémie il
faudrait répondre à d'autres enjeux de
sécurité de protection civile donc il ya
un vrai sujet de prise en compte de la
protection civile dans notre pays
la deuxième hypothèse c'est se donner
encore peut-être plus ambitieux que cela
et faire comme d'autres pays européens
ou tout autre au travers le territoire
la planète certains pays ont pris
l'orientation de faire en sorte que la
protection civile sont positionnés soit
auprès du premier ministre soit un
véritable ministère dédié à la gestion
des crises d urgence et de la protection
civile
enfin et pour conclure je souhaitais
évoquer le fait que cette réorganisation
elle doit s'appuyer s'appuyer sur quatre
piliers essentiels le premier gène
évoqué en introduction
c'est l'unicité de commandement je suis
désolé mais au quotidien
les forces de police les forces
militaires les sapeurs pompiers nous
avons un seul chef
nous y répondons et cela évite la
cacophonie le deuxième sujet c'est la
résilience de la population la
fédération nationale et bon nombre
d'acteurs qui sont à vos côtés
que ce soit le collègue de seine et
marne ou de la plaque parisienne
christophe prudhomme nous savons que
lorsque la population résiliente
lorsqu'elle est préparé lorsqu'elle est
finalement formé aux gestes qu'ils
soient blancs ce cas les habitués à
répondre à des situations d'urgence elle
nous accompagne
elle nous aide elle nous protège en me
permettant justement une bonne alerte et
une capacité aussi adapter les bons
gestes à face à la situation de crise
le troisième élément c'est le
développement du volontariat le
renforcement du volontariat
il faut des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels il faut des sapeurs
pompiers militaires dans les deux unités
plus les formations militaires de la
sécurité civile
que ce soit pareil marseille et la
sécurité civile mais il faut des sapeurs
pompiers volontaires dans tout le
territoire
il y a un plan qui est en cours de
développement par le ministère de
l'intérieur
il faut lui de redonner un nouveau
souffle il faut que la directive qui
avaient été engagés par le précédent
ministre
et que souhaitait également le sénat sur
l'engagement citoyen et civique soit
portée au niveau européen nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui pour la réponse au
quotidien et notamment de l'exceptionnel
d'abord des citoyens engagés qui sont la
résilience de nos territoires les
sapeurs-pompiers sont les premiers
maillons de cette résidence des
territoires et enfin pour terminer je
voulais revenir sur la consolidation de
nos services de santé aux services de
santé sont des gens professionnels ou
volontaires qui sont dans les hôpitaux
qui viennent servir les dix qui
permettent le suivi médical nos
personnels mais qui concourent à l'aide
médicale d'urgence qui permettent
justement d'intervenir dans une
situation gravissime tels que les
attentats tels que les feux de forêt
tels que le kobe de 19 mais aussi
également permettre cette régulation
médicale accompagner et permettre au
samu de toujours être plus efficace avec
les serpents pompiers et enfin je
clôturerai par un point qui nous
tiennent à coeur
je sais qu'ils avaient d'autres acteurs
autour de la table nous partageons c'est
ce sujet que j'ai déjà évoqué en
séparant en faisant la dichotomie entre
l'appel d'urgence et l'appel delà du non
urgents le jour
nous allons séparer en france ce que
d'autres ont fait déjà depuis des
décennies nous arriverons à faire non
seulement à répondre beaucoup mieux à
nos concitoyens et deuxièmement à faire
travailler nos services d'urgence tous
ensemble la volonté de la fédération
nationale des sapeurs-pompiers de france
de manière générale c'est de travailler
ensemble
nous le savons toutes et tous et
monsieur le président il me semble que
vous êtes d'un département du sud
lorsqu'il ya un feu de forêt dans votre
département
ce sont les sapeurs pompiers qui sont à
la lutte il ya énormément de services
qui agit sous l'autorité d'une seule
personne
le préfet pour faire en sorte que la
cause du sinistre soit résolu et faire
en sorte que les conséquences soient le
plus possible éviter merci monsieur le
président merci colonel merci de me
rappeler que dans ma ville il ya eu un
feu de 4 hectares il ya deux jours dr
frieden jouait sa parole
ce que décrit le colonel allione est la
résultante de l'absence de prise de
décision et d'une situation qu'on
connaît depuis très longtemps
il est clair que quand deux services
publics qui ont vocation à travailler
ensemble ne travaillent pas ensemble au
quotidien que leur collaboration repose
plus sur les individus et sur les
personnes que sur une doctrine à une
stratégie nationale
eh bien on arrive à la situation qu'on a
connu il est clair que cette guerre
entre les rouges et les blancs c'est une
réalité ça a été une réalité ça reste
une réalité et dans une des plus grandes
métropoles mondiales qu'est paris la
situation est catastrophique est
catastrophique aucune interconnexion
entre les deux systèmes informatiques
cirque en appelant appel soit le 18 ou
le 15
l'adresse est enregistré dans un système
informatique et l'opérateur que ce soit
un opérateur pompiers où l'assistant de
régulation médicale prend son téléphone
pour retransmettre par fo ni l'adresse à
son collègue pour qu'on puisse organiser
la chaîne des secours quand on sait que
chaque minute compte
comprenez bien que la perte de minutes
essentielles sur un arrêt cardiaque fait
que nous sommes un des pays où
indépendamment du fait que notre
population pratique peu les gestes de
secourisme
nous avons de très mauvais résultats sur
la prise en charge d arrêt cardiaque
donc voilà donc quand en plus de chaque
côté nous avons une pression importante
en termes de moyens que ce soit les
pompiers avec les conseils
départementaux qui ont des difficultés
budgétaires ou l'hôpital et si on l'a
deux systèmes qui sont sous pression
financière et qui n'ont pas les moyens
et qu'en plus il ne collabore pas eh
bien on se retrouve dans une situation
de crise qu'on a connu c'est à dire que
tu as voulu donner un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé très rapidement
j'étais de garde quand la ministre de la
santé agnès buzyn annonce au journal de
20h que quand on a un doute sur une
éventuelle infection
il faut appeler le 15
une heure après notre standard a explosé
voilà une catastrophe c'est à dire que
un responsable politique prend une
décision sans s'assurer qu'elles
puissent mettre elles puissent être
mises en oeuvre par son administration
écoutez et ce d'autant que du fait de la
préparation parce que voilà on a passé
notre temps à faire des projets sans les
mettre en oeuvre
mais on n'a pas eu un retour
d'expérience des précédentes crises
parce qu'à la suite de la grippe h1n1 et
des attentats il était prévu que nos
standards puisse avec simplement un
bouton augmenter leurs capacités
moi je travaille dans le 93 un
département qui a été le plus impacté
nous avions 60 lignes 60 lignes vous
comprenez bien que quand il ya une
augmentation du nombre d'appels émis en
est saturé et ça a pris un temps certain
avant qu'on puisse augmenter la capacité
notre auto comme et pouvoir recevoir
tous les appels et indépendamment de sa
vous savez que le mouvement des urgences
là je prends ma casquette de
syndicaliste
- d urgence et dans les familles
réclament du personnel supplémentaire
donc on peut avoir un bon lot comme
messi a personne pour décrocher demain
et deux oreilles
eh bien on est en difficulté et nous
avons pu effectuer une montée en charge
que de manière très progressive parce
qu'il y avait à la fois des moyens
techniques et les moyens humains à
mettre en oeuvre et donc effectivement
pendant toute une période des gens
appelaient que ce soit pour un
renseignement
l'inquiétude par rapport à coronavirus
et ça pourrait être aussi un infarctus
un arrêt cardiaque
avec des délais de décrocher de 30
minutes et les appels qui
n'aboutissaient pas parce que quand les
lignes sont saturés et appelle
n'aboutissent pas donc le problème est
là c'est à dire que déjà dans un premier
temps avant qu'on envisage de nouveaux
numéros de téléphone
si vous savez entre une décision entre
le moment on prend une décision moment
on applique un en particulier dans notre
pays
ça prend un certain temps aujourd'hui
les moyens informatiques nous permettent
d'avoir une interconnexion ce qui existe
dans certains départements
ou que le citoyen appelle le 15 ou le 18
c'est transparent
est-ce que les gens se parlent
travaillent ensemble a même des centres
de régulation en commun mais y'a pas
besoin forcément d'être physiquement en
commun mais le même système informatique
on sait où sont les moyens pompiers
on sait où sont les moyens des samu et
on les utilise au mieux et quand il ya
besoin de ce qu'on appelle cette chaîne
de survie
c'est à dire utiliser le maillage du
territoire assurée par les pompiers qui
sont des secouristes professionnels qui
arrivent avec de l'oxygène leur
technique un défibrillateur et le samu
qu'à un voyage mains danser qui met 10 à
15 minutes de plus pour arriver dans
certaines zones dans notre territoire un
peu plus longtemps donc il ya une
urgence aujourd'hui à travailler
ensemble
mais là on a un problème de doctrine
parce que la doctrine du ministère de la
santé et d'une partie des médecins une
partie des médecins qui sont à la tête
des samu est en contradiction totale
avec ce que nous sommes un certain
nombre à défendre sir quel est le bon
territoire pour qu'on travaille ensemble
sachant qu'il ya trois interlocuteurs la
ville l'hôpital et les pompiers et bien
c'est le département est pas la région
or aujourd'hui le ministère de la santé
ferme des seins nus départementaux avec
l'aide des médecins pour concentrer des
plateformes régulation régionale
comprenez bien que quand déjà au niveau
du département on n'est pas en capacité
décrocher si on fait encore plus grand
ça dysfonctionne et donc c'est
l'actualité en octobre 2018 le samu de
la nièvre a fermé et le directeur
général de la rs bourgogne franche comté
en plein c ur de la santé se déplace à
auxerre pour annoncer que le plan de
fermeture du samu reste d'actualité à
objectif 2022 2023
contre l'avis des élus locaux contre
l'avis des personnels toutes catégories
confondues contre l'avis des pompiers
départementaux
donc il ya un problème et c'est un
problème politique au sens noble du
terme c'est à dire comment peut-on vivre
dans les territoires et quels sont les
services publics dont on a besoin et
sachant que qu'à chaque euro est compté
et bien
il faut essayer de collaborer pour que y
ait des gains d'efficience
donc nous sommes dans une situation
aujourd'hui de crise grave
c'est à dire que l'hôpital continue à
fonctionner de son côté et les services
d'incendié et de secours est bien avec
leurs multiples missions mais comme l'a
dit le coller la lionne les feux ne sont
pas leurs activités principales au
quotidien c'est bien le secours à
personne et donc il ya nécessité
aujourd'hui qui est une stratégie
clairement énoncé avec un maillage du
territoire
voyez aujourd'hui c'est pas sérieux que
les hélicoptères sécurité civile et
qu'on les disait que tu kopter blanc du
samu qui soit sous traité à des boîtes
privées qui nous coûtent très cher et
qu'on a un maillage du territoire avec
plein de trous dans la raquette
voilà est-ce que c'est ça la réalité
vous aller de l'autre côté du rhin vous
avez un système héliporté vous savez
c'est simple on prend un combat on
tracer un cercle autour du rayon
d'action des hélicoptères on regarde si
tout le territoire découvert là
aujourd'hui entre à la sécurité civile
et samu on n'a jamais pu réaliser cette
carte on n'a pas de compass en france
alors être ça donc nous les personnels
de terrain
nous travaillons au quotidien avec les
pompiers et on demande et nous sommes
très heureux
en tout cas en tant que syndic elle je
suis très heureux d'avoir été invité à
cette commission denquête pour dire que
on a beaucoup souffert dans cette crise
et on demande des moyens mais dans les
moyens il ya aussi de l'organisation et
l'organisation pour nous aider à mieux
travailler plutôt que d'être dans une
impasse qui aujourd'hui font que des
gens baissent les bras en disant je vais
pas continuer à travailler dans ces
conditions là voyez et on a des gens qui
partent de l'hôpital public
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont très déçus
l'organisation des moyens des conditions
de travail donc il ya urgence
aujourd'hui d'avoir un plan avec des
mesures immédiates à moyen et long terme
et si à long terme ça sera peut-être le
numéro unique 112 ya davantage
inconvénient c'est à discuter la
question c'est le citoyen quand ils
appellent pour une urgence alors avec
quand même un petit bémol par rapport à
ce que disait le colonel alion
le citoyen quand il appelle le sait pas
ce qu'est l'urgence pour lui tout est
urgent donc ce tri et la régulation est
importante c'est la raison pour laquelle
il ya avantages inconvénients à
plusieurs numéros un la question c'est
au faut qu'on fasse le tri il faut qu'on
mutualiser nos moyens
les systèmes de téléphonie moderne et
informatiques permettent très rapidement
de le faire même si nous ne sommes pas
physiquement au même endroit et surtout
ce qui est le plus important
et là je vous demande et vous êtes des
sénateurs vous représenter les
territoires
il faut stopper stopper ce qui est
contenu dans la loi à ma santé 2022
la régionalisation des samu et la
concentration des moyens dans les
métropoles et la désertification des
territoires
là je reprends ma casquette de médecins
et pas de syndicaliste
quand un citoyen et à plus de trente
minutes d'un service d'urgences et de
l'arrivée d'un véhicule du samu et bien
le principe constitutionnel d'égalité de
traitement de tout citoyen quel que soit
son lieu de résidence sur le territoire
n'est pas remplie et c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle il ya une certaine
défiance de la politique
les gilets jaunes les mouvements sociaux
etc parce qu'une partie de la population
et dans la population via les personnels
de santé qui travaillent dans ces
hôpitaux de proximité se sentent
complètement abandonnés et face à une
politique de rouleau compresseur qui les
déçoit beaucoup et font que risquent de
baisser les bras on aujourd'hui nous
manquons de professionnels de santé déjà
pour faire fonctionner le système donc
gardons ceux qui sont en poste et
donnant l'espoir aux jeunes que demain
sera meilleur qu'hier et qu'aujourd'hui
merci bien monsieur delebecque vous avez
la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames
messieurs merci pour cette invitation
je vais essayer de vous présenter les
choses telles que la vue un directeur de
samu et un chef de service des urgences
qui a également la responsabilité d'être
conseiller médical auprès du grade
ile-de-france qui développe et déploie
tous les systèmes d'information de santé
régionaux et je suis également directeur
médical de la première école d'art m de
la région ile de france auprès de
l'assistance publique
le cette crise bien évidemment c'est
organisé selon différents niveaux et
vécu de l'hôpital et d'une direction de
sa mur on l'a vite mise en place et on
l'a vite comprise tout d'abord il y
avait la rs qui était en pilotage avec
des réunions quotidiennes auprès des
directeurs d'établissements auxquels
étaient associés des présidents de cme
dont il y avait une double compétence
qui était présente pour les samu nous
avions une réunion journalière des huit
sa bulle afin de coordonner et de
permettre de mettre en place les moyens
dont nous disposions puis surtout de
bénéficier de l'expérience de chacun
puis bien évidemment la taille de chaque
établissement une cellule de crise a été
mise en place
en tout cas en tant qu opérateur local
cette organisation était une
organisation qui était clair et qui nous
a permis de pouvoir mettre en oeuvre un
certain nombre de solutions dont je vais
vous parler
par la suite sur les aspects de
l'innovation et sur les organisations
bien évidemment on a fait on a fait face
à une crise qui est tout à fait
inhabituelle avec des volumes de prise
en charge que ce soit téléphoniques ou
de patients à l'hôpital en réanimation
qui ont et qui ont surpris tout le monde
on va le dire comme ça qu'ils ont
surpris tout le monde le colonel allione
faisait remarquer que ce soit le
standard du samu et des pompiers
les volumes étaient telles que de toute
façon il fallait bien pouvoir s'adapter
à un moment et que c'était pas une
question de couleur de standard
téléphonique qui était en jeu mais bien
évidemment il fallait pouvoir avoir
quelques éléments d'organisation et
d'innovations techniques qui ont été
présents puisque les réactions sur la
capacité à mettre en oeuvre pour pouvoir
faire face en tout cas pour la partie
que je représente
quel samu a été de quelques jours en
quelques jours nous avons été en
capacité d'absorber un volume d'appels
qui dans certains départements était de
+ x 10 1 x 10 le nombre d'appels dans le
mien ça a été pas recette
et tant d'un point de vue technique avec
anouk grades des autos comme qui était
très conséquent autant qu'une
mobilisation des personnels qui étaient
très conséquente aussi à titre d'exemple
au samu j à peu près une 4 90 personnes
qui travaillent entre médecins arm et
notre personnel nous avons eu recours à
de l'aide extérieure qui est arrivé à
plus de 250 personnes qui se sont
mobilisées pour venir travailler dans le
samu 250 personnes ça veut dire que au
lieu d'être à 15 ans elle de régulation
nous étions entre 45 et 50 et bien
évidemment nous avons intégré tous ces
personnels là en moins d'une semaine
vous imaginez le défi et vous imaginez
les prouesses organisationnel qui ont
été mises en place une solidarité bien
évidemment très importante donc on a
parlé des moyens humains on a parlé des
moyens techniques bien évidemment j'ai
eu un petit mot sur les moyens
techniques tout de même nous avons eu
quand même la chance d'avoir un certain
nombre d'outils qui nous ont permis
d'avoir en temps réel la disponibilité
des places de réanimation sur toute la
région et compte tenu de la tension qui
existait sur la région au moment le plus
dur de la crise il ne restait plus que
14 lits de réanimation sur la région
donc les évacuations les évacuations qui
ont eu lieu vers la province ont quand
même soulagé de plus de 250 lits ça
n'est pas rien et il aurait fallu faire
encore des efforts locaux pour pouvoir
augmenter les capacités qui était déjà
extrêmement forte puisque les capacités
ont été augmentés de foix iv à x 5 en
fonction des établissements
à titre d'exemple l'hôpital de melun qui
a vingt places de réanimation a pris
plus de 110 patients en charge et se
retrouve en réanimation en réanimation
je dis bien et se retrouve à la 5e ou 6e
place des établissements qui en ont le
plus pris donc on voit bien quand même
les éléments de l'adaptation qui ont été
mises en place toujours sur l'innovation
et la vigilance je ferai un petit point
je suis vraiment sur le terrain je suis
moins sûr l'organisationnel que tout à
l'heure mais néanmoins ça se je pense
que le miroir et est important sur les
ehpad nepad ont été un sujet de
discussion majeure pendant toute cette
crise beaucoup de d'établissement
beaucoup d'acteurs de santé ont mis en
place des organisations je crois très
innovante puisque au regard de la
mortalité dans les ehpad en tout cas
dans 77 et particulièrement dans mon
établissement en tout cas dans mon
établissement nous avons fait le
diagnostic en avant dans les ehpad que
les patients pouvaient décédé du coït
bien évidemment mais décédé également de
l'isolément et du confinement et qu'il
était très compliqué de lutter à c
contre cette situation la part des
effets bien évidemment on le sait tous
un que les ehpad ont des effectifs qui
sont un petit peu en difficulté qu'il y
avait beaucoup de malades dans les ehpad
dans le personnel aidant les médecins
également et que du coup on se
retrouvait dans une forme évidemment
entre guillemets de déshérence les
initiatives qui ont été prises ont été
de constituer des groupes
multidisciplinaire gériatre urgentistes
hygiéniste infectiologues et
secouriste qui se sont déplacés dans
toutes ces ehpad et qui brutalement
brutalement ont fait baisser la
mortalité en donnant des soins simples à
qui étaient des soins véritablement
habituel pour des problématiques de
pneumopathies ou de réhydratation liés
au confinement et on est revenu à des
taux de mortalité qui était taux de
mortalité équivalent à une période qui
était normal nous avons nous eu une
rupture un jour donné on avait 47 morts
une journée à partir du moment où nous
sommes intervenus
nous sommes revenus à cinq morts sur les
vingt-sept ehpad dont nous occupions
donc il ya vraiment des équipes qui ont
été très positifs
je sais que chaque établissement a
essayé de mettre en place à l'échelle de
son département des phénomènes de ce
type là bien évidemment chacun a pu le
faire à la hauteur de ses moyens sur les
relations avec les partenaires
c'est évidemment temps de crise qu'on
améliore des relations avec ses
partenaires ou en tout cas qu'on les met
en oeuvre en fonction de ce qui a été
fait dans les années précédentes elles
ont été bonnes avec les associatifs
globalement sur la région pour ce que je
peux en dire en tout cas dans mon
département des arts construite elle
était un peu inexistante historiquement
je reviendrai pas sur le passé mais ça
nous a permis de passer
j'allais dire une étape qui était
intéressant qu il ya une mobilisation
des ambulances privées également qu'ils
étaient très intéressantes et et pour se
dire rebondir sur ce qui était dit sur
les sapeurs-pompiers les interactions
d'abord son réel au quotidien moi je
suis dans un département mais les cadres
de la grande couronne et les cadres de
la petite couronne sont en cours mais
les cadres de la grande couronne sont
interfacés avec les sapeurs-pompiers et
donc sur les créations dossier nous
transférons des dossiers de façon
informatique de façon à pouvoir
récupérer l'information et ceci
fonctionne bien ce qui n'a pas empêché
d'avoir des officiers sapeurs-pompiers à
ma demande qui sont venus en régulation
du samu pour pouvoir faciliter le lien
c'est à dire que le lien informatique
est une chose le lien organisationnel et
présentiel est une autre chose mais les
deux était possible et je sais que je
n'ai pas été le seul
elle fait bien évidemment les sapeurs
pompiers dans ces collaborations
participer au tri à l'entrée des
établissements
et puis et puis les relations sont
polymorphes d'un département à l'autre
donc je ne ferai pas de généralités en
tout cas il ya des situations où la
collaboration a pu se faire il ya eu des
situations je crois qu'ils ont été plus
difficiles mais ça n'est pas à moi de
faire le détail de chaque département
bien évidemment je me doute l'enjeu
médical notamment par rapport à la
régulation
il est très fort à quoi sert la
régulation maïs ra pouvoir avoir une
entrée partagé et une entrée commune
pour tous les patients ayant une
nécessité de soins notamment non
programmés donc ils servent à faire un
tri et il sert à essayer de faire entrer
au mieux le patient dans un parcours de
soins ça ce sont des métiers qui sont
développés depuis 20 à 30 ans
aujourd'hui nous avons des écoles d'art
m auxiliaires de régulation médicale
qu'ils ont ouverte sur tout le
territoire y en a onze en france si on a
une à paris que je voulais dit tout à
l'heure
et bien évidemment ce sont les premières
secondes ce sont des 30 premières
secondes qui sont fondamentales pour
pouvoir faire ce tri et essayer de bien
faire entrer les patients dans les bons
parcours de prise en charge
c'est ce qui a été fait pendant cette
crise c'est à dire qu'on a eu des armées
de décrocheurs qui se sont mis en place
qui ont été formés et qui dès l'appel
avec encadrement ont pu ré adressez-le
appel à des compétences qu'ils n'étaient
pas les mêmes entre les gens qui
nécessitait d'avoir une intervention
pour un arrêt cardiaque pour un accident
pour toute autre raison bien évidemment
et pour le coc vide donc on a montré
pendant cette période que cette on va
dire cette idée du saas tel qu'il est il
a déjà été décrit en tout cas sa mise en
oeuvre a fonctionné et ça nous a permis
d'absorber encore une fois les volumes
d'appel qui était x 4 x 5 x 6 soit 7 des
appels qui se présentait en régulation
alors l'autre élément qui a été qui est
intéressant dans cette organisation là
c'est que le samu n'est qu'un hub le
téléphone n'est qu'un hub
dans les services de santé c'est à dire
que nous comment est ce qu'on s'est
organisée pour faire face à des choses
qu'on connaissait mal on a fait venir
des infectiologues en régulation
on a fait venir des gériatres en
régulation avec qui on faisait des
points avec qui on s'organisait donc on
voit bien que la régulation elle elle
est multidisciplinaire elle ne repose
pas que sur les médecins urgentistes
néanmoins cette multidisciplinarité elle
se fait dans un contexte de santé qui
doit être un contexte de santé partagés
voilà ça c'est un point qui est très
important alors l'autre élément quand
même c'est que en effet il nous a fallu
quelques jours pour passer d'un volume
d'appels sur moi qui est de l'ordre de
1100 appels par jour à 7 milles par jour
il a fallu 4 5 juin pour pouvoir y
arriver
néanmoins l'organisation con con qu'on a
mis en place nous a pas permis d'avoir
un système dégradé permettant de
répondre c'est pas ça qui s'est passé
c'est que nos taux d'appel qui étaient
des taux d'appels qui nous satisfaisait
pas tout à fait historiquement et et sur
lesquels on travaillait depuis de
longues années
eh bien on est passé à des taux de
décroché qui sont de 100% à des taux de
perte d'appel qui était de zéro donc en
fait on s'est adapté de telle façon et
avec les moyens à des renforts que l'on
en a qui ont fait que l'on a pu tous
avoir un service vis-à-vis de la
population qui n'avait jamais été
atteint alors vous imaginez bien que ma
demande derrière ça c'est qu' on puisse
conserver des moyens qui nous permettent
d'avoir cette efficacité l'un et sans se
dire dire deux choses extraordinaires je
pense que tous mes collègues des autres
ça vu l'espère également bien évidemment
le renfort et les organisations à
l'hôpital ont été absolument fondamental
et on voit bien aussi qu'il ya une
nécessité de pouvoir avoir ces
organisations et serrant fort et être en
situation de pouvoir faire face au
volume et riz dont je vous ai décrites
la conclusion à que je pourrais
peut-être donner des éléments que je
vous donne c'est qu'on a eu
véritablement des échanges qui sont des
échanges avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaires dans une crise qui quoi
qu'on en dise tu es une crise de santé
même si ça concerne beaucoup de
partenaires et de services différents
évidemment on n'est pas seuls au monde
et puis on ne voudra jamais l'être et le
samu ne veut pas être au centre de la
situation bien sûr mais si cette
expérience pouvait nous permettre de
consolider en termes d'effectifs nos
possibilités de pouvoir rendre le
service que l'on a aujourd'hui bien
évidemment nous tirions un grand
bénéfice de la situation
d'autant que l'expérience nous a montré
que finalement le je vais dire des
effectifs supplémentaires
c'est de l'ordre de 10 15 20 % maximum
et là on a des services qui sont
vraiment de très grande qualité
voilà je vous remercie merci beaucoup
monsieur je vais passer la parole au
rapporteur mais comme je suppose qu'ils
vont aussi interroger et monsieur
vermeulen et le médecin colonel hussein
axigen pardon je vais leur demander à
tous les deux prêté serment alors
monsieur vermeulen d'abord prêté serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et deal je
jure on vous a pas entendu je le jure
bessat colonel patrick hertz guen donc
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité ait levé la main
droite et dit je jure je le jure jane
merci merci pour la précision
j'ai donc passé la parole maintenant au
rapporteur comme la schl à la bourgogne
a été mise en avant
j'ai d'abord passé la parole à madame
vermeillet
merci monsieur le président l merci à
vous messieurs pour les cochons du show
pour vos témoignages
[Musique]
je fais poser une question tout d'abord
au docteur prud'hommes oui par rapport à
la bourgogne franche comté j'ai bien
suivi les épisodes avec la rs je partage
totalement ce que vous avez dit la même
façon que je partage l'inégalité d'accès
aux soins sur les territoires
je suis élu du jura mais lorsqu on nous
ferme par exemple des maternités avec
les femmes droit de faire deux heures de
route
quand il n'y a pas de neige pour
rejoindre une maternité c'est
particulièrement compliqué donc les
enfants ont le droit de naître au bord
de la route donc effectivement je
souscris totalement à vos propos vous
avez parlé de de l'organisation qui
n'est pas satisfaisant de la saturation
des standards des appels les mauvais
résultats que ça avait produit notamment
en cas d'arrêt cardiaque
vous avez dit pendant toute une période
les gens appelés et nous avions des
délais de décrocher de 30 minutes
pendant toute une période est ce que
vous pouvez caractérisé toute cette
période
le délai et puis surtout ce qu'on a
besoin de savoir dans cette commission
denquête c est ce que vous avez idée du
nombre de victimes que c'est
désorganisation a provoqué est ce que on
entend parler dans cette commission des
pertes chance et des dysfonctionnements
notamment par rapport aux prises en
charge
mais est ce que quelqu'un connait est-ce
que vous avez vous à votre connaissance
idée du nombre de victimes que cela a
généré
ensuite j'aurai une question pour le
colonel alion vous avez dit que vous
aviez eu la perception de tout sauf les
sapeurs-pompiers que vous aviez pu avoir
la perception d'être mis de côté comment
ça s'est caractérisée
est ce que c'est juste une impression ou
est ce que vous imaginez que un moment
donné il ya une directive qui fait
qu'effectivement les sapeurs-pompiers
étaient mis de côté voilà merci
allez-y vous pouvez répondre oui
donc je vous ai parlé de l'intervention
de madame busan le 24 nous avons pu
avoir les outils techniques sur les
autos comme nous avions renforcer le
personnel mais sans avoir de ligne
supplémentaire que le 13 mars donc du 24
janvier au 13 mars
heureusement après le 24 janvier il ya
eu un pic et puis ça s'est un petit peu
tassés mais fin février-début début mars
le nombre d'appels a très fortement
augmenté et nous avons eu les deux
autres
barrette de l'autocommutateur le 24 mars
donc comme les jets mon collègue le
docteur delebecque nous avons
effectivement multiplier le personnel et
nous avions effectivement des gens
disponibles
on a utilisé les étudiants en médecine
nos collègues médecins qui avaient vu
leur service fermées qui n'avait plus
d'activité en partie que des biologistes
des radiologues qui sont venus nous
aider en régulation mais voyez qu'il ya
un délai très long avant de pour une
raison très simple à la suite d je le
répète à la suite de la grippe h1n1 et
les attentats il avait été prévu que
nous ayons ces barrettes d'auto comme et
qu'on puisse les activer en moins de 24
heures
elles n'étaient pas installés donc
appelé les installer bon quelle que soit
la rapidité de mobilisation des
techniciens ça prend du temps il faut y
compris nous avons aménagé les salles a
fallu percer des trous dans les murs
pour faire passer les câbles
je sais c'est là c'est la téléphonie
informatisé donc le nombre de victimes
c'est comme pour le l'épidémie comment
la virus nous ne savons pas combien de
personnes sont mortes du grenat virus
nous avons une sur mortalité globale
c'est comme pour la grippe
traditionnelle ce qui est clair c'est
qu'on commence à avoir quelques éléments
sur le fait qu' un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont restés à domicile qui
avaient des formes peu graves
enfin au téléphone et donc on limitait
les hospitalisations parce qu'on avait
des problèmes de capacité d'accueil
ces gens sont en fait des complications
qu'on appelle thrombo emboliques et sont
morts d'embolie pulmonaire
voilà donc ça nécessite de faire des
études
voilà on n'en est qu'au début mais il
est clair que la prise en charge des
patients n'a pas été optimale comme vous
le dites vous même c'est une perte de
chance pour l'instant on peut pas
chiffrer mais dans le cadre de la
surmortalité que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui
il est clair qu'il faudra faire le tri
et la part des choses bien sûr nous nous
sommes organisés
on a fait le maximum
mais faut pas rosir les choses je pense
que si on veut être préparés pour
l'hiver prochain
il faut se dire les choses même si
parfois il ya des maladresses il peut
faire des noms d'oiseaux qui vole comme
je voulais dit ces problèmes existent
depuis très longtemps et aucun
gouvernement quelle que soit sa couleur
n'a eu le courage politique de mettre ce
dossier sur la table pour qu'on puisse
avancer et que les deux services publics
les plus appréciées des français que
sont les sapeurs-pompiers et les
urgences et les samu ne travaillent pas
ensemble c'est oui il ya des endroits on
travaille ensemble mais d'une manière
générale on n'a pas de doctrine
clairement défini qui permette que sur
l'ensemble du territoire national les
choses aillent bien ça ne peut pas rose
posée que sur des individus j'insiste là
dessus et ça c'est de la responsabilité
du politique souhaité répondre
non
pendant vous souhaitiez répondre aux
questions de notre rapporteur change
jamais juger de délais de prise en
compte du son nom de trois éléments
comme premièrement j'entends le collègue
chef du service du samu dans en seine et
marne
effectivement tout tout tout a pu se
faire mais tous ces faits je dirai au
pied levé et excusez moi le terme parce
que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
artisans
mais il s'est plutôt fait de manière
artisanale que préparer anticiper
planifier et quand je connais la
formation exigeante drm qui sont des
gens de grande valeur qui répondent au
quotidien à la détresse de nos
concitoyens c'est vrai que l'on est très
étonné quand quelques minutes on est
plus fort mais d'autres collègues afin
de la régulation donc il ya tous ces
éléments qui ont été de la bonne volonté
de toutes celles et ceux qui ont dû
faire face à ce flux d'appels et on a un
document chiffré mais je suppose que le
collection du service à 1077 à des
éléments chiffrés et documenté mais
effectivement on a des relevés de donner
des réponses
et quand on sait que pour la réponse à
l'arrêt cardiaque il faut que l'on soit
dans les 30 secondes ce n'est pas moi je
n'ai pas la capacité de dire cela ce
sont des études de médecins et de
professeurs qui ont prouvé que s'il en
arriver répondre dans les trente
secondes à une demande de secours dans
dans le cadre d'un arrêt cardiaque
on avait énormément de chance de sauver
or tous les deux que l'on a eues dans
cette période là était au delà des 30
secondes on a étayé nous dans notre un
autre synthèse et pour autant dans
d'autres pays
en autriche au danemark dès l'instant où
on a séparé l'urgent du non urgents la
crise du coville n'a pas eu d'impact sur
la prise d'appels donc ce c'est un sujet
certainement de personnel que je que je
méconnais parce que je ne suis pas au
plus profond des centres hospitaliers
notamment des centres de traitement de
l'alerté des saluts mais en tout état de
cause c'est un sujet aussi
organisationnel
maintenant pour répondre très exactement
à madame la sénatrice du jura et vote
rapporteuse une somme comme elle et nous
connaissons très bien le jura puisque
nous avons un membre éminent
au sein de notre comité exécutif qui est
dans votre département
nous sommes contre la régionalisation
des samu nous sommes contre
l'organisation régionale de la réponse
urgente pour une seule et unique raison
c'est que la proximité la réactivité
c'est le succès et la sécurité de nos
concitoyens ça c'est le premier élément
sur le deuxième sujet pour répondre
exactement votre question nous demander
si le tout sauf pompiers sauf les
pompiers a été a été un mot c'est une
perception mais il ya trois exemples je
prendrais premièrement lorsque sur la
plaque parisienne il est arrivé des
hélicoptères typiquement de l'armée de
la sécurité civile il y avait des
ambulances préparer des ses propos de
paris et à mon année on leur a refusé
l'accès pour ses transferts là ça a duré
quelques jours ça c'est corrigé par la
suite on peut en retrouver des images
sur les réseaux sociaux certains ça
n'amuse d'ailleurs mais pour autant il
ya eu oui des moments où les ambulances
onge n'étaient pas autorisées à aller
sur les tarmacs pour récupérer les
patients faire des transports intéresse
pitallier alors que c'est ce que l'on
nous demande aurait régulièrement
même lorsque nous avons un traité de
l'urgence et que les ambulanciers privés
pourraient être justement active est
sûre c'est sur ces interventions la
première exemple deuxième exemple à
besançon un hélicoptère de la sécurité
civile armé par un collègue médecin
sapeur-pompier a dû débarquer le médecin
sapeur-pompier a dû débarquer pour
permettre justement un collègue du samu
de monter
l'ordre est arrivé de paris troisième
exemple j'ai déjà cité c'est les
colonnes de vers savait qu'ils avaient
été préparés par la cour
la région rhône alpes la zone sud est
qui ont été démontées auront laissé
d'autres vecteurs faire du transfert de
patients voilà trois exemples qu'il nous
faut avoir ce sentiment là je n'ai pas
la preuve
effectivement qu'ils aient eu un mot
d'ordre est heureusement qu'il ya eu des
gens intelligents qui ont permis
justement de doute repasser cette
sentiments ou 7 où ce mot d'ordre s'il a
eu lieu mais connaissant certains
individus on suspecte
oui des mots d'ordre
c'est bon madame de roche la parole à
merci monsieur le président plusieurs
questions la première concernant les
personnels qui ont été intégrés en
régulation vous avez fait un peu
référence au profil mais si vous pouvez
nous préciser comment vous êtes montée
en charge parce que c'était question je
me souviens que j'avais posé lorsque fin
du tout début mars on a vu un débat un
débat et je m'étais interrogé sur le
fait que de toutes orientées sur le 15
comment le 15 allait préparer à répondre
aux appels
deuxième question sur la place de la
ville hier on entendait des médecins
généralistes ou infirmiers pharmaciens
d'île de france et qui se sont plaints
de ne pas avoir été intégré au
dispositif tôt du fait peut être aussi
qu'il y avait ce ce départ sur le 15
au début après e marche arrière et puis
aussi sûrement le fait qu'ils étaient
sous équipés et de fait une crainte peut
être aussi les patients des cabinets qui
avait été fermé quel est votre sentiment
sur cette place de la ville concernant
la rupture de soins lors d'une audition
précédente la commission des affaires
sociales veut nous habiter avec votre
collègue était tendue qui semblerait
qu'ils auraient des chiffres en effet
d'arrêt cardiaque important sur la
région parisienne supérieur du moins à
la normale est-ce que ça ça a été si
vous avez des statistiques sur sa par
rapport à des ruptures de soi ou alors à
des non possibilité de joindre les
services d'urgence
est ce que vous sentez une reprise de
l'activité en milieu hospitalier
par rapport à votre regard que vous avez
sur vos propres établissements une
reprise de l'activité qui permettrait
justement de pallier ces difficultés
liées aux la rupture des soins lors de
l'orientation des patients comment on
faisait est ce que vous aviez une
gradation dans l'orientation des
patients
et ça c'est très spécifique à
l'ile-de-france par rapport aux
établissements hospitaliers ap-hp autre
en fonction des capacités de ces
établissements à recevoir les malades
selon la gravité de ducasse maison on
sait que certains sont plus spécialisés
certains services plus spécialisés que
d'autres où on mettait tout le monde
bien sûr dans les services puisqu'il y
avait un besoin de place et qu'ils
soient accueillis
mais comment s'est faite cette
orientation le directeur de la rsi hier
à un sigle navetteurs de l'ap-hp nous
ont dit en avait en effet un plan disant
que si vraiment il y avait une surcharge
énorme on aurait peut-être et réduit les
critères d'admission en urgence en
réanimation nous ont dit que ça n'avait
pas été fait parce qu'ils se sont jamais
retrouvés à ce point de rupture est ce
que ça vous le le confirmer et l'autre
point c'est en effet les médecins de
ville nous ont dit je reviens un peu 25e
session d'hier qu'ils avaient 1 1
un standard dédié qui était réservé aux
professionnels de ville mais avec des
temps d'attenté qui avait pu être
considérable parce qu'il nous est
parfois nous mêmes professionnels de
ville ont souhaité appeler parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on sentait pas pas bien
et on a sur lequel on a besoin conseil
de spécialisation il avait des temps qui
parfois était de l'ordre de 40 ou 45
minutes et ma dernière question elle est
pour le colonel donc dans votre note
vous dites les préfets semble avoir été
relégué au second rang dans la gestion
la crise en raison d'une absence de
dialogue avec les ars et leur prise en
main de la gestion la crise n'a pas été
homogène
jusqu'au 2 avril lorsqu'il a fallu
préparer le déconfinement alors semble
c'est un peu comme quand on fait des
textes de loi y ait des termes qu'on
n'utilise pas parce que ça d'être
appelés gilles préfet semble c'est pas
d'une grande précision
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner nous
dire bah oui en effet c'est ce qu'on a
quand même entendu sur le terrain où
lorsqu'on auditionnait des dents toutes
les auditions qu'on a fait avancer leur
accueil son enquête
lorsqu on additionnait différentes aux
personnes ou professionnels on nous
disait bien selon les départements
les liens entre ars et vous direz sur la
départementale et préfets dans certains
cas ça marche très bien
la coordination se faisait bien et dans
d'autres c'était totalement séparés ce
qui a été préjudiciable à l'effet que
l'efficacité du la prise en charge
donc est-ce que vous pouvez être un peu
plus précis que ceux semble et nous
donner un oui en disant voilà il ya eu
tel cas tel cas il faut qu'on est en
effet une vision département par
département comment les choses se sont
passées si on veut remédier à remédier
et pallier toutes les difficultés
rencontrées
merci président merci manu roche
je vais d'abord passer la parole donc à
monsieur prudhomme puis monsieur drevet
qui colonel préparer votre réponse pour
la dernière question se prénomme
non nous avons bricolé on a fait avec ce
qu'on avait nos jeunes d'étudiants se
sont mobilisés ils ont beaucoup appris
sont d'ailleurs très satisfait c'est une
expérience mais bon une expérience qui
s'est fait aussi sur le dos les patients
on peut dire m là quand on est
inexpérimenté on sait qu'on fait les
erreurs est bon malgré la formation
l'encadrement qu'on pouvait leur fournir
on a mis en première ligne brutalement
avec voilà quelques heures de formation
des gens qui avaient toute leur bonne
volonté mais c'était difficile des
jeunes et des moins jeunes eu des
collègues la soixantaine biologiste
qu'on a mis en régulation j'étais un
petit peu inquiets qu'ils sont rendus
compte c'était beaucoup de bon sens
parce que en fait on avait un tri des
appels grave pas grave ils prenaient les
pas grave et il y avait beaucoup de
conseils donc au bout de quelques appels
il avait repris confiance la place de la
ville luis catastrophique
la centralisation par les ars est une
catastrophe au niveau régional c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas utilisé la ville et
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui y compris
c'est difficile là dans mon département
on a un foyer à saint-ouen c'est la rs
qui veut tout organiser j'étais de garde
au samu au moment où il y avait le
problème à saint thois personnes nous
avait prévenus
on savait pas qu'il y avait un foyer
sainte foy en salle de régulation à
bobigny donc voyez la circulation
d'informations quand c'est entre alizé
c'est compliqué et puis surtout
aujourd'hui alors qu'on a quand même un
bruit de fond qui va persister n'y a pas
de reprise l'épidémie mais un bruit de
fond avec des malades et il y en a
quelques-uns qui ont un vrai animations
c'est sur le collègue de ville qu'il
faut s'appuyer pas sur un système
administratif centralisée mais qu'on
leur donne les moyens de pouvoir faire
les tests les dépistages c1 qui
connaissent les familles qui sont dans
les quartiers voilà le voyez pour être
un peu brutal moi je suis assez cash
dans les ars également de remplir un
tableau excel quoi le problème c'est
quand ils ont étudié le tableau excel a
déjà passé un stade plus avancé de
l'épidémie est ce qui était vrai beyer
n'est plus vrai le lendemain voilà donc
voilà ça nous a mis à six en colère
gradation de l'orientation des patients
rupture oui voila moi je dis clairement
si vous avez auditionné monsieur
rousseau et mon monsieur hirsch
mon directeur général nous avons été en
rupture il n'était pas sur le terrain
voilà on a retardé la prise en charge de
patients tout retard à la prise en
charge en traîne une surmortalité nous
n'avons pas la capacité de mettre les
patients immédiatement réanimation donc
on les a menés dans les services
d'urgence
en attendant voir comment ils évoluent
est alors qu'ils auraient été beaucoup
mieux dans un livre animations on
n'avait pas sévi
et puis ensuite on nous a imposé de
manière autoritaire une stratégie qui a
été celle des tgv sanitaires dans les
transferts de patients oui pour la
région grand est mais en ile-de-france
qui ne déploie métropoles mondiales nous
avions des locaux des locaux dans les
hôpitaux vide
il nous paraissait quand même
intéressant de discuter du choix de la
stratégie est ce qu'il faut faire c'est
tgv sanitaires ou est ce que il ne faut
pas transféré du personnel et du
matériel dans des locaux qu'on peut
aménager très rapidement merci à nos
intervenants mais je commencerai par par
l'intervention des pompiers par les
questions que le président me l'on leur
avait posé
moi je suis super plex je suis perplexe
parce que j'ai entendu le colonel tout à
l'heure nous dire y'a pas de guerre
entre les rouges et les blancs mais
qu'est ce que ce serait si avait la
guerre après les propos que je viens
d'entendre venir ce serait ça ne sais
pas quoi à l'apocalypse ou ou la fin du
monde mais pour être sérieux
je suis ceci dit complètement dans cette
remarque mais le président me l'on vous
a posé des questions précises sur des
constats qu'il a lu dans votre pré
rapport et vous avez fait une réponse
qu'on connaît parfaitement
c'est un document de travail ça n'a pas
été validé et cetera et cetera
je vous remercie beaucoup pour cette
réponse mais moi j'en voudrais une
précise de réponse oui ou non est ce que
les constats qu'a rappelé alain milon
ont été faits par des membres de votre
profession ou par des pompiers
oui ou non
après monsieur le président j'ai
rapidement cinq questions à poser et je
voudrais revenir en fait aux faits parce
que avant de refaire une construction
politique qui va jusqu'au ministère je
voudrais qu'on comprenne et notre
population a le droit d'avoir des
réponses à des questions simples
la première de ces questions c'est elle
s'adresse à vous droit et 3 et
particulièrement au docteur de l'uec et
prud'hommes est-ce que vous avez été
appelés pour des personnes âgées en
ehpad qui présentait des symptômes de
qu'ovide nécessitant une hospitalisation
et qui n'ont pas été hospitalisés est
parti à man pour françois dolbec
il nous a fait part de situations en
ehpad avec des chiffres assez terrible
de mortalité qui ont été réduits après
l'intervention du samu si j'ai bien
compris
est ce sur instruction que ces
interventions ont eu lieu ou est ce que
c'est une initiative locale
deuxième question est-on mort oui ou non
en france en mars avril de défaut de
soin à votre connaissance
troisième question et 4e questions qui
sont liées parce que lors d'auditions
précédente
il ya une question de savoir s'il y
avait eu des pénuries de médicaments ou
non donc
avez vous eu connaissance de cas de
réduction de l'usagé des médicaments
réanimation par exemple où on n'aurait
pas utilisé des sédatifs en continu mais
seulement lors de la mobilisation des
patients par ailleurs concernant les
matériels
y at il eu ou non des effets de pénurie
des pousse seringue qui aurait conduit à
mélanger différents produits dans les
pousse seringue et enfin dernière
question est ce que des personnes qui
auraient été admise en réanimation hors
périodes de cette pandémie ne l'ont pas
été voilà ce sont cinq questions qui
nécessitent des réponses courtes et je
vous remercie la précision devant
réponse colonel
vous pourrez répondre aux questions de
monsieur jomier qui étaient les miens
l'avant
comme vous entend pas alors donc j'avais
omis d' allumer le micro je disais il ya
un certain nombre de questions sur
lesquelles je ne me permettrais pas de
répondre compte tenu que je ne travaille
pas en réanimation que jeune administre
pas de médicaments donc j'ai pas toutes
les capacités pour répondre et je ne
saurais pas y répondre on se dit qu'ils
étaient spéciales là les docteurs
prud'hommes et de relever que répondront
d'accord sur le sujet du pré-rapport
très clairement les sapeurs-pompiers de
france et la fédération
le rapport que vous avez entre les mains
dorénavant et un rapport sur lequel nous
avons vérifié toutes les remontées de
terrain
donc ce qui est indiquée est exact ce
qui est indiqué c'est ce que nous
percevons c'est ce que nous savons est
ce que nous avons constaté
donc si demain matin vous demander dans
quel endroit il ya eu pression sur la
diminution du niveau de sécurité des
pompiers sur calendes dans le quel
endroit il ya eu ce taux de réponse aux
appels dans quel endroit il ya eu cette
intervention
tout à l'heure j'ai cité trois exemples
c'était factuel et c'était exactement ce
que l'on sait maintenant on vous dira
que dans le pré-rapport il était nick
indiqué typiquement qu'il y aurait pu y
avoir des morts si les délais de réponse
tout ça on ne peut pas le mesurer
vous voyez bien même que les collègues
médecins ne peuvent pas le mesurer ne
peuvent pas vous le donner donc c'est
pas le petit sapeurs-pompiers que nous
sommes qui va pouvoir vous lui donnez
tout simplement avec beaucoup d'humilité
vous savez on a voulu faire son retour
d'expérience parce que nous avons vu
constaté qu'il y avait eu des
manquements au respect de tous qui
avaient été programmées écrit et que
tout ce que nous souhaitons mettre en
oeuvre pour mieux
justement répondre à nos concitoyens
avaient été complètement occultés dans
cette phase de crise et lorsqu'on est en
situation de guerre
je vais répondre sur le sujet des ehpad
lorsqu'on est en situation de guerre
c'est à peu près toutes les sept
secondes ce que nous vivons savez quand
un chat d'agréer à un fourgon
pompe-tonne je ne souhaitais pas
exploiter cette métaphore mais je vais
l'exploiter lorsqu'un chef d'agrès un
fourgon pompe tonne se retrouve face à
une façade et qu'il y a le feu il y a
deux appartements en feu vous avez un
appartement vous avez une personne de 30
avec son enfant dans les bras vous avez
un seul vecteur aérien et de l'autre
côté vous avez une personne âgée ou et
il marqué que je doit disposer l'échelle
à un endroit qui doivent tomber en
premier
donnez moi la réponse mais c'est le
travail de nos chefs d'agrès au
quotidien donc lorsque vous posez la
question sur les ehpad
je pense que les professionnels de santé
peuvent vous répondre aussi il y
certainement vu des choix nous étions en
temps de guerre nous avons des officiers
de sapeurs pompiers nous avons des
sous-officiers de sa panoplie qui
répondent au quotidien à des situations
tactiques dramatique
par contre la position de ces sapeurs
pompiers elle est écrite dans aucun
livre il devant le juge régulièrement
nous répondons aussi de nos actes c'est
cela la situation de crise c'est cela la
situation de guerre voilà monsieur le
président vous oui excusez moi colonel
je vais reprendre deux secondes je vais
reprendre les phrases que je vous ai
cités tout à l'heure pour essayer
d'avoir des réponses plus précises de
votre part aux questions de monsieur
juillet je vous ai dit quand même que
vous avez écrit qu'il y aurait eu des
pressions sur les territoires en tension
pour abaisser le niveau de protection de
leurs agents vous avez aussi écrit vous
fait les sapeurs pompiers des requérants
des récurrents des requérants pardon non
qu'ovide en situation d'urgence vitale
non jamais jamais eu de réponses du 15 à
leur appel et sont morts dans
l'indifférence générale
et vous avez écrit aussi les évacuations
par tgv serait de pure opération de
communication
ça a été écrit ça n'a pas été dit c'est
ce qui a été écrit dans un rapport
est-ce que vous contestez ces écritures
ou est-ce que vous les assumez parce
qu'après tout les assumer ça veut dire
qu après ceux qui sont accusés dans ces
trucs pourront se défendre mais pour
l'instant même la réponse que vous venez
de faire un bernard jomier
personnellement ne me satisfait pas j'ai
le président je vous ai répondu de
manière très claire content j'ai
l'impression que soit mon propos ou soit
vous souhaitez que je
les assume ce qui ne sera pas le cas
compte tenu qu'ils ne sont pas dans la
version finale
le document de travail et un document
qui a permis à 250 milles personnes de
s'exprimer notamment au travers de
l'ensemble des conditions que nous
possédons je ne peux pas assumer un
travail qui était rédactionnellement
perfectible en revanche le fait qu'il y
ait eu pression dans les territoires oui
ça s'est passé
le fait qu' il y ait pu y avoir des
morts vous avez eu la question posée aux
collègues médecins qui n'ont pas pu
répondre je n'aurais pas l'outrecuidance
d'y répondre aussi et le dernier sujet
c'est sur les opérations de
communication notamment sur les tgv je
pense que je me suis exprimée de manière
exhaustive et précise je pense oui qu'il
ya eu certainement une volonté de
communiquer sur ses opérations de
transferts de malades alors qu'il y
avait certainement d'autres possibilités
plus habituel plus régulière mais moins
glitter comme on dit en communication
certainement merci monsieur prudhomme
oui pour pour rebondir effectivement la
première version du rapport était assez
agressive donc il ya des précisions qui
ont été apportées concernant les
évacuations par tgv
je partage je partage complètement et je
me suis exprimé là dessus
au nom des organisations dans les médias
c'était une opération de communication
c'est mon travail au quotidien un malade
ventilé avec des pousse seringue le
transfert une première fois dans une
ambulance
ensuite d'une ambulance dans un tgv vous
avez pu voir que ces tgv n'était pas des
tgv sanitaires c'était du bricolage
il aurait mieux fallu organiser lé
convoi d'ambulances
si effectivement la stratégie la bonne
stratégie avait été de poursuivre les
évacuations
j'ai clairement affirmée avec le soutien
d'un certain nombre d'élus locaux dont
la ville de paris qui avait une autre
possibilité qui était de réarmer des
locaux hospitaliers qui était existants
et j'ai même signifié à aux sénateurs
qu'ils m'ont interrogé il ya quelques
temps avec mon
collègues gerald kirneck que martin
hirsch avait menti quand il avait dit
qu'on ne pouvait pas utiliser les locaux
de l'hôpital de l'hôtel dieu parce que
les pluies n'était plus fonctionnel dans
l'eure
j'ai demandé à des collègues ouvriers
d'aller vérifier c'est fluide c'est
fluide et est disponible après que y est
par contre robert sait pas mais question
du taux légal il avait déjà abordé ce
point là il serait temps de répondre aux
questions directement comme médocs la
question la question là dessus c'est que
le transfert le risque qui a au retard
en une prise en charge dans un lit de
réanimation et il ya eu des retards
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure et je le
répète quand effectivement nous prenions
en charge un patient et que nous étions
en difficulté pour trouver un lit de
réanimation malgré le fait que une
cellule a été mis en place que nos
patients fasse un arrêt dans un service
d'urgence en attendant la place en
réanimation ensuite que la place en
réanimation est à 50 km
c'est prendre des risques pour ce
patient voilà et donc ça on sait que
statistiquement et il ya des données
françaises internationales qui ont été
publiées dont une étude en france qui a
été piloté par le chu poitiers qui
montre que tout retard à la prise en
charge en réanimation d'un patient
nécessitant ce type de technicité c'est
une surmortalité de 30 % voilà donc faut
être clair on a travaillé en mode
dégradé
on a fait ce qu'on a pu en ce qui
concerne les ehpad
nous nous sommes arrêtés au fil de l'eau
mais initialement
initialement il y avait plus de places
en réanimation et donc nous avions
tendance à laisser un certain nombre de
personnes dans les ehpad
il y avait le rapport bénéfice risque
avec de l'oxygène et en faisant des
prescriptions plutôt que lé transfert à
l'hôpital parce qu'on était en surcharge
ensuite comme l'a dit mon collègue
heureusement qu'un certain nombre de
collègues de ville en particulier et des
collègues hospitaliers se sont rendus
dans les ehpad et on n'a jamais eu une
meilleure médicalisation que quand on a
eu ses collègues qui ont été dans les
ehpad
ça a été fantastique parce que là
effectivement on avait des médecins
d'examiner
sion et qui faisaient effectivement de
la vraie médecine non ce patient il ya
des directives anticipées
on le soulageant le laisse on n'est pas
ce qu'était le choix de la famille du
patient
celui là il nécessite alors l'animation
je le vois donc on lui trouve une place
en réanimation
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on a travaillé
mais dans un premier temps nous avons
freiné la prise en charge des patients
en ehpad parce que nous n'avions pas
assez de lits de réanimation
donc c'est un retard à la prise en
charge des grèves et une surmortalité
sur les médicaments
vous avez vous même vu les directives
qui n'ont été ni nationalement puisque
nous avions sur des médicaments sédatifs
n'était en difficulté donc on a
substitué certains médicaments par
d'autres bons ils sont moins maniable
mais c'est pas une dégradation
catastrophique de la prise en charge
on a essayé de faire avec ce qu'on
pouvait voilà on a bricolé avec les
moyens du bord on était effectivement à
la limite en termes de respirateurs sur
les respirateurs simplement pour vous
dire que quand on ventile un patient
avec un respirateur de secours d'urgence
ou deux qu'on a dans les véhicules du
samu ce n'est pas un respirateur de
réanimation sur les poumons très dégradé
et c'est pas l'idéal est juste une
petite 1,6 c'est que les respirateurs
une autre opération médiatique qui ont
été construits sont des respirateurs que
dans mon service nous mettons
aujourd'hui au rebut comme matériel de
secours parce que ce sont des machines
obsolètes
voilà donc ça a été aussi une grosse
opération m'a dit qu'en diront en disant
on va construire dix mille respirateur
sauf que c'est pas des respirateurs pour
équiper des lits réanimation voilà c'est
les choses qu'on la dit quand on est
dans le retour d'expérience il peut y
avoir controverse sur un certain nombre
d'éléments on peut ne pas être d'accord
mais de ne pas vouloir aller jusqu'au
bout de la controverse pour trancher un
moment donné moi je dis pas que j'ai
raison sur tout mais je suis pour qu'on
mette sur la table l'ensemble des
dysfonctionnements qui se sont produits
pendant cette période parce que si on
veut s'améliorer pour la suite
et vous savez le problème des lits de
réanimation je termine là dessus chaque
hiver chaque hiver monsieur juillet
chaque hiver j'ai des soucis dans mon sa
mue en ile de france pour trouver des
places de réanimation pour les personnes
âgées qui viennent des ehpad
chaque hiver c'est pas qu'au moment de
la crise parce que j'ai des collègues
réanimateur qui me dit écoute ta
personnel à 85 ans tulasne aux urgences
et puis on verra alors que moi en tant
que médecin je considère que au regard
de son dossier
et voilà une analyse la situation il
faut la mettre en réanimation on verra
ensuite quel sera son évolution
sauf qu'on n'a pas suffisamment de lits
de réanimation chaque hiver et donc eh
bien on est obligé effectivement de
mettre des patients en attendant les
services violent et stérile de médecine
et parfois ils vont en réanimation 2 3
heures ou 24 heures après et leur état
s'est dégradé et ça ça s'appelle une
perte de chance monsieur alors les
questions sont nombreux jeux je reprends
deux éléments qui ont été dit auparavant
dans l'exemple qui nous a été
des cris entre une personne jeune et une
personne âgée est un élément de choix
j'avoue que je suis assez mal à l'aise
par l'exemple qui était donné
l'organisation qui a été mise en place
et qui était mise en place
selon les connaissances médicales au
moment où elle existait et je crois que
nous l'avons tous vu ses connaissances
médicales ont évolué au fur et à mesure
du temps il est vrai qu'au début de la
crise on nous a expliqué à tous à vos
yeux jeu franchement tous d'accord que
au delà d'un certain âge la mortalité
était de quasi 100% pour les patients
qui dépassait un certain âge quand il
avait locaux vides jeu là par contre je
ferai pas de commentaire sur cet aspect
là si vous voulez monsieur le président
donc on l'a appliqué donc on l'a
appliqué
collectivement c'est à dire que bien
évidemment la réanimation du fait de son
mode de fonctionnement en fonctionnement
normal quotidien aujourd'hui ce matin
cette nuit demain fait un tri des
patients qui vont réanimation et la
connaissance de la maladie faisaient que
nous faisions collectivement tous avec
l'immense bienveillance qu'on pouvait
avoir du tri d'accès en réanimation
notre connaissance a changé elle a
changé brutalement parce qu'on s'est
aperçu en faisant par nous mêmes et par
certains collègues devine en faisant par
nous mêmes les visites on n'est pas
quand même comme vous avez équipe
d'urgentistes à qui vous expliquer cet
après-midi en fait tu vas arrêter de
faire la médecine d'urgence et du smur
et tu vas faire la visite en ehpad
parce qu'il se passe des choses qu'on
comprend pas vous savez vous avez la
surprise en face de vous un il faut
accompagner les équipes sur ce genre de
choses et le retour que vous avez est de
dire on est très étonné parce que en
fait ça se passe pas tout à fait comme
on pensait que ça se passerait et donc
on a adapté et puis le constat a été
partagé et le constat a fait qu'on a
écrit des recommandations
ces recommandations qui était au début
locales sont devenues régionale puisque
on les a transmises à la rs ou les a
transmises à tous les partenaires et ça
c'est fait selon un process qui est un
process j'allais dire assez vertueux de
prise en charge mais il n'y a jamais eu
à ma connaissance
ma connaissance la com de décision de
dire non c'est pas possible on peut par
non quand on disait impatient on ne va
pas l'emmener en réanimation voir on va
plutôt le laisser dans l'ehpad et
l'accompagné parce que là il est
vraiment pas bien
eh ben on le faisait dans la
connaissance scientifique que nous
avions en ce moment là et ce qui était
considéré collectivement comme étant la
meilleure situation
l'accord ge j'insiste sur cette démarche
là parce qu'elle est vraiment importante
et alors elle répond de façon un petit
peu longue à la question alors
évidemment quand on est le changement
dans nos pratiques ont changé
donc on a augmenté le nombre de patients
qu'on a
envoyée aux urgences et probablement
qu'on a accepté en réanimation
donc est ce qu'il ya eu un décalage
entre deux périodes la réponse est oui
est-ce que ce décalage il est dur parce
qu'il ya un moment on ne voulait pas le
faire-- à et tout d'un coup on a voulu
le faire la réponse est non c'est
simplement qu'on avait des niveaux de
connaissance qui n'était pas d'aimer ça
c'est la première chose sur la pénurie
de matériel je crois que je vais être
mauvais experts parce que on en a
beaucoup parlé oui on a manqué
globalement deux respirateurs et ça n'a
pas été simple d'en avoir oui on a
fabriqué du matériel où on a demandé à
des fabricants à côté des hôpitaux qui
avaient des imprimantes 3d de nous
fabriquer des raccords de nous fabriquer
des choses comme ça et que ça a été
quand même quelque chose d'assez
compliqué oui ça c'est fait
bien sûr est-ce qu'on a utilisé toutes
les drogues qu'on utilise au quotidien
habituellement pour tous les patients la
réponse est non on a utilisé des drogues
anesthésique qui permettait d'avoir des
sédation qui était décéda sion de
qualité pour pouvoir passer ces moments
là est ce que on n'était vraiment pas
loin des limites qui sont acceptables
oui sûrement
oui sûrement mais en moins nous avions
un comment dire nos réserves
opérationnelles de psm qui étaient
disponibles qui avaient été rendus
disponibles pour les réanimations et
donc qui sont localisés dans quelques
établissements de la région
ça a été mis à la disposition des
réanimations aider ça me elles n'ont pas
été touchées
d'accord donc il y avait cette
possibilité là donc n'étions pas loin
mais ça n'empêche qu'elles n'ont pas été
touchés après le un dernier point deux
derniers points excusez moi sur le
nombre de morts est l'arrêt cardiaque
sont deux sujets différents je m'excuse
de revenir dessus
le fait qu'ils aient plus arrêt
cardiaque est un sujet le fait qu'ils
aient eu des morts par déficit de prise
en charge est un autre sujet et je vois
là je préfère le dire parce que ça n'est
pas tout à fait le même
la même discussion et puis je me permet
de terminer par sage je suis un petit
peu désolé parce que je vis un quotidien
qui est d'une autre nature
je suis un petit peu choqué de des
points de vue exprimés vis-à-vis de
certains de mes collègues
où on personnalise des difficultés qui
me semble pas être à propos dans cette
gestion de crise nationale donc je
l'évoquent je suis quand même assez
choqué de cette situation voilà pour
cette audition des services d'urgence
mobilisées pendant la crise sanitaire
une audition devant la commission
denquête du sénat sur la gestion de
cette crise du coc vite 19 et durant
cette audition le président de la
fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers grégory allione a
dénoncé une gestion trop administrative
de l'épidémie il a également critiqué le
transfert des malades en tgv vers les
régions les moins touchées par le
coroner virus c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi vous
pouvez revoir tous nos programmes sur
notre site internet publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
sur public sénat
à
[Musique]